[Music]
come on
[Music]
the contentious relationship between
youtube and crowder has been heating up
in this country all people are equal
before the law but in a few short years
all peoples around the globe were
electrified to learn that what vox
dreamed of but could not accomplish came
to a thundering realization with
youtube's lightning-like targeting of
conservative voices
this show
mug club and its viewers are linked
together in their cause
against big technology
and their creed
will defend to the death your right
to free speech fighting for the cause
like good comrades
to the utmost of our strength
mug club
shall go on to the end
we shall fight
on the youtubes
we shall fight on the twitters and the
instagrams we shall fight with
unwavering confidence and growing
strength even in the face of
demonetization
[Music]
we shall defend
every channel whatever the cost may be
we shall fight
against the liberal media
we shall fight in the quarantined
reddits we shall fight in the young
turks comment section we shall fight
at the ted talks we shall fight with our
retweets and our likes and we shall
fight with all our shirts and with every
irritating distasteful
sketch and we shall never ever surrender
[Applause]
and if
which i do not
for a moment believe
this show and its supporters were
subjugated or shadow banned an armored
club
beyond all youtube armed and guarded by
the half asian kraken will carry on the
struggle until in god's good time the
new free online world with all its power
and might steps forth to the rescue and
liberation of the council
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
break the grip of the youtube gestapo
and join at ladderwithcrowded.com
today
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
speedy
[Music]
hot uh
glad to be with you this morning i wish
it were under uh you know what no i i i
will say under joyous circumstances here
because
we got something for you so
couple of warnings right off the bat if
you have kids i recommend they not watch
this show because i'm matt
three two you've had enough time
it's not a trigger warning it's a
potential language warning because i
cannot make the promise
that it won't slip uh also if this gets
removed
uh if this episode is not available or
if we do not tell you that we are not
doing a show we are always available
monday through thursday live 10 a.m
eastern rumble or mug club where today
will be playing uh uh is it guess that
gender uh guess the pronouns guess the
pronouns today very nice
so let me start this off to let you know
you all know about what's happening
with uh libs of tick-tock this is
happening this morning right now it is
9 30 central 10 30 eastern for those who
can't
go through the anguish of adding one
um
this is a pattern it's a pattern of
attack
and i want to be really clear about
something here we've been through this
this is one of the only programs that
has survived
uh the pattern is very clear i'll
explain to you what the pattern is i'll
explain to you what the end game is and
we will be here right now to defend our
friends
we're not just defending our platform
we're not just defending this show
that's how
how you judge
someone or how you at least get a sense
for what they believe in is what do they
do
when someone who
can offer them effectively nothing uh
someone from whom they stand to gain
nothing is under attack
and that's a big part of what we do it's
a big part of why we fight like hell and
i tell you what libs of tick tock i know
reached out this morning um
full disclosure we've been speaking with
them we've spoken with them of course in
the past because you know we run the
same circles uh we've got your back okay
so we're going to be talking about that
uh today quite a bit before any so let
me ask you this is journalism dead this
is the question of the day you know
what's happening at washington post is
it taylor lorenz taylor taylor lorenz
for some reason my head i'm thinking
lorenz larkin who's a fighter it's just
lorenz i'm horrible with names
point is not the same awful awful human
being and let me just clarify on the
outset i of course no one here is
encouraging you to do what taylor lorenz
has done in harassing in doxing in going
after family members no one
no one here is being called to
or advised to do that as a matter of
fact i am begging all of you pleading
that you don't
we've been pretty you've all been pretty
good about that here we're pretty one
thing that i will say i'm proud of and i
don't think it's too arrogant to say the
fan base that we have we see it when we
go out to live shows
and we often see it in the comments
section you are decent people and i know
we've got to fight fire with fire this
is going to get ugly
but don't do the things that uh either
will get you removed or we all know to
be wrong
because you do lose that moral high
ground and you know it's it's
if you lose the moral high ground with a
washington post reporter
you've done something really bad
so is journalism dead
and should we you know what we i think
of course look that's rhetorical and uh
who should bury it
i'd love to piss on the ashes okay
gerald a how are you i am doing better
than you no i'm fired up i'm ready no we
should be ready i am absolutely you know
what else i'm really worried about i i
really hope that libs of tiktok
understand we've seen this i'm more
worried about uh
the the right wing ecosphere the i don't
want to use the term grifters that's
overused but people capitalizing on the
trend and then forgetting about them
talking about the lawyers the
non-profits the nightly news shows
they'll be everywhere and guess what
there will be a new story tomorrow we
will still be here we know what it is
that you're doing we know what it is
that you bring to the table and we've
always valued it we love their work
we've featured it many many times
support them wherever you can uh also uh
he's here i was just talking about how
great the people are at the live shows
he has a show by himself uh solo april
30th in green bay wisconsin he's made it
and then we will be june 18th uh pikes
peak center colorado springs or spring
still some seats left for the sec the
early show the early version right in
june it's in june sorry i didn't did i
say june yeah you did june 18th i
thought you were correcting me no no i'm
i'm
my brains and fast forward right now
which happens when i'm enraged
see i told you you were angry it's that
white male rage or maybe it's that
you're an [ __ ]
i think that's true lando dave how are
you is that it me no boy
i'm just glad uh we all accidentally
wore the same thing today yeah i know
what oh look at that i know
that's crazy thank you i got new shirts
you know
all things are bad no not all things are
but no it's not bad here's the thing
this is why we fight this is why we are
here
well also obviously to make you laugh
and to uh you know oh and you will yeah
yeah i don't know about that today well
there's some stuff in here sometimes
people think it's funny when i get
furious i don't little but it's like oh
all i have to i feel like nightcrawler
all i have to do is go through the
portal of hell to teleport well
wonderful
i'm glad everyone else gets to reap the
benefits
all right
so we're going to cover libs of tick
tock uh late not later we're going to
cover it immediately very quickly but uh
before that because of course now
the the whole reason for this is the
media wants to put you on edge they want
you to be afraid to now feature libs of
tick tock they want you to be afraid
they want you to put distance between
yourself and lives of tift hey do you
know you know where that happened before
by the way little historical context
bring that up
andrew breitbart i say i and your
breitbart i sat under the tutelage of
that guy
that guy did
the acorn uh sting he orchestrated it
with hannah giles and james o'keefe
and he was everywhere all over fox news
all over media and then something
happened with shirley sherrod where bill
o'reilly took a clip out of context and
blamed andrew breitbart for selectively
editing it he never did he was persona
non grata
at all of conservative media until he
actually hijacked anthony weiner's
podium because the media was ready to
say that andrew breitbart was faking
pictures of his dick
weiner's dick wiener's wiener
yes and andrew breitbart actually
hijacked the podium at anthony weiner's
press conference where he was about to
go out there and say there's the there
are these right-wing smear
campaigns
being lobbed against me and guess what
the media was just ready with their
notepads to eat it up and i remember
andrew brepper he was going through and
there are stories about this you could
hear people yelling i believe it was at
a hotel i don't know where it was i
don't know if it was the omni you could
hear them say
andrew bart's in the building
and only after that he had a claw his
way back was he allowed back in the good
graces of conservatives probably the
most effective and the most influential
conservative of our time and he was
taken from us far too young
everyone turned their back on him i was
there for it i watched it i watched him
go through hell and it was hell that he
never deserved for a mistake he never
made i don't want to see that happen
again
that's why we're here so while they want
us to create distance between ourselves
and libs of tick-tock
let's do a quick watch in react today of
this uh
beautiful brave person telling us why we
are not allowed to define
women
here is madison cawthorne's death oh
lord of a woman guys i'm gay chromosomes
no tally whacker
and this gives me a chance to talk about
biological issues
biological essentialism first of all
it's not true people have all kinds of
chromosomes and all kinds of bodies
women who've had hysterectomies people
born with certain conditions but that's
almost immaterial
what are you doing in my house it is a
system of oppression
gender is a hierarchy
and a system of oppression and you're at
the top because you're just a white dude
is to define gender the easier it is to
keep the oppression
going oh yeah dangerous oh this is what
they always do with the victim thing and
we'll talk about that a little bit first
off take off the lipstick
take off the lipstick little charlie
brown curl uh yeah if you saw that neck
and you were a doctor you would say you
are grossly unhealthy you are unbel you
are so underweight it's dangerous that's
basically a walking snoo with a chin
but because now we have to deny science
and deny biology we go oh no that's
perfectly fine if you saw an average
straight white male that thin you would
know it's unhealthy but
we abandon all reason at the door yeah
absolutely and we just did what libs of
tick tock does they let you display you
exactly we didn't do anything there
laziest i was excited by the beard i
guess but uh it's a beard and lipstick
and it's like why are you you're not
crying oh okay you're committed huh i
mean i just don't even know how you
included at that point i guess it's just
under it's just under queer by the way
queer could just be a straight guy who
occasionally likes wearing rouge
is that what's what's the [ __ ] hat
going to be next time it's just a
flaccid penis with eye shadow i don't
know how this works
yes
and that's a good point we'll talk about
that too libs of tick tock what are they
guilty of here's and let me first set
the stage
this happened with us this has happened
many times
we were fortunate enough to only be
demonetized that's why mod club matters
uh so much we are actually funded by
viewers like you not federal grants
or a foreign caliphate
here's what happens
nonprofit is used medium usually media
matters yeah
they do the dirty work they put together
a hit piece they put together a hit a
highlight reel this is what happened
with us exactly then they get
legitimized by a mainstream outlet like
washington post like nbc which is what
happened with us and then social media
allows it to trend gives it the right of
way trending
everywhere algorithmically selecting
which
which content you see
and then they aim to cancel you
de-platform you let's be clear when we
say cancel remove your livelihood yeah
from the public square and this is what
they do non-profit media matters
highlight reel legitimize it through
some legacy media outlet social media
lets it trend boom cancel that is the
order
always there's some variation there in
maybe a different person does the real
maybe a different outlet posts it
but this is how it works and the reason
they are doing this with libs of tick
tock just to be clear
before we get to anything else you know
what their sin is lives of tick tock is
doing exactly doing exactly what you say
you want
and by you i mean everybody everyone
says we're all in our own echo chambers
now we all just uh you know we only see
the content that we want to see what
does libs of tick tock do they take
content from the crazy alphabet
blogosphere and tick tock world
unedited
they don't change the context
and then they make it available to
people who don't live
in that carnival tent
and when people say hey this is crazy as
they react to it because they're not in
their own ecosphere
see you can't call us crazy and now
they're the victim and they want to
remove the people who are bridging that
gap hey
bridging the gap and getting people out
of your own echo chamber
is uncomfortable it should be
uncomfortable it's why the alphabet
mafia it's why the gestapo it's why
modern progressives cannot live in
reality
you can't handle the criticism you
remove people who do it there's there
isn't even any commentary they're just
posting their own stuff
well you might as well just get mad that
you looked in a mirror
i'm sure they did well and you put it in
a public space it's not like you posted
this to your friend group and somebody
went in there and grabbed it and like
put it out to the world and you didn't
want them to see it but they do this
with everybody they de-platform people
and now you have no ability to defend
yourself so here's here's the scenario
stephen just played out libs of tick
tock gone right so if they get canceled
not if we have anything to say about it
we won't let that happen obviously but
now they can't go out there and correct
any of this story because you're going
to read the washington post and go wow i
didn't know this account was spewing all
this hatred oh my gosh because that's
what they're saying in the washington
post like they're saying anti-lgbtq aaip
group somebody spewing hate out there
totally smearing these people going
after teachers and making them quit
their jobs no what's actually happening
is we're taking the video the teacher
did and putting it online yeah it's
already there we're putting it in front
of your face that's it but they can't
say that they they must operate now
they're gone yeah they're not telling
you how to think they're just taking the
video that's there and you see it yes
exactly if that's hate speech that's
your fault for being so goofy yes that's
really just self-loathing you have to
kick your own ass i'm sorry astonishing
it's fear and self-loathing and folsom
street yes
it is just yeah that's exactly what is
happening at this point and um no not if
we have anything to say about and we'll
get to that a little bit so let me
defended people who have this has
happened to before even people who we
don't agree with 100 right they've just
been locked up i know alex jones has
caused a lot of controversy when he's
come on the show but we're like look
maybe the guy has a chance the guy has a
chance to defend himself just like
hopefully you do yeah we never levied
with these kinds of we had alex jones
obviously gavin mcginnis we had uh
stephen williford after the sutherland
springs shooting we had uh kyle written
house as soon as we could yeah and if we
haven't had them on we've reached out
people like nick said all of these
people we've always said look you
deserve the ability to at least tell
your side of the story but i'd like to
do more than that with libs of tick-tock
um let me sort of set the stage here uh
a little bit i've already set the stage
let me explain to you what's going on so
this story a hit piece in the washington
post oh and by the way
never mind let me just let me get to
this clip first so that you know what
we're dealing with so much here
uh was created it was written by a
professionally useless person taylor
lorenz
now taylor lorenz uh in case you don't
remember recently made news on msnbc for
the cry fest about uh people doing
exactly what it is that she does here
only worse for a living here's a
refresher i had severe ptsd from this i
i contemplated suicide it got really bad
you feel like any little piece of
information
that gets out on you will be used by the
worst people on the internet to destroy
your life
and it's
so isolating
and terrifying
it's horrifying
i'm so sorry
it's overwhelming
it's really hard
in your opinion in my opinion that last
part when she said and terrifying and
you went back to her and she's like
i'm so sorry yeah look
it seemed as very sincere yes it was
very oscar-worthy yeah can we be acting
like you might see on the suite life of
zack and cody i just i i i want the
audience to close them when they when
they go to the reporter and she says and
terrifying i think that's what she said
when it goes back just watch her face
and keep it keeping this is just our
opinion
no idea that it seems it seems fake and
[ __ ] yeah the lack of tears and emotion
is why yes
these are generally signs of crime of
some kind of grieving yes yes yes yes
perhaps being upset yes rattled yeah
decision
yeah piece of information not stirred
that gets out on you will be used by the
worst people on the internet to destroy
your life
and it's
so isolating
right after this terrifying
it's horrifying
looks like that was an edit
i'm so sorry
that right there yeah look is that okay
guys i'm not saying she's not sad and
not broken up about this i'm saying that
moment right there seemed not here's the
thing and this is also one thing too
people women don't understand this
sometimes well a lot of women do these
women don't when i say the i mean these
women if a guy does that if a guy fake
cry i'm just we lose friends i would
quit i would quit the show right now
rightfully yes it's unacceptable it's
terrifying and overwhelming do you mean
like i don't know a crazy journalist
showing up at the house of your
relatives um well it's amazing that she
would do the same thing if it's so
offensive and sad i think we're looking
for overlay uh overlay oh
no he's so entranced he is definitely
interesting the picture we have a
picture of them showing up at the house
there we go
meryl streep
yes
disabled so it's interesting they sent
this out earlier it's like huh so you
hate it when people do that yeah exactly
and by the way this wasn't years ago
this was a couple of weeks ago that she
put she went on like the beginning of
april this is in the piece washington
post by the way all the references
available at louder.com see look we kind
of do the same thing that's why i feel a
brother sisterhood with libs of tick
tock they're just showing you what
should be publicly available or already
is we make all of our references
available what other programs do they
don't then they try and criticize the
fact that we do well we're using
washington post today how about that now
what are you gonna do they went to and i
don't know exactly who when it's not
clear someone uh associated with the
washington post piece
went to uh the house of well and so
ladies and gentlemen and also called the
family members right so liv's a tick
tock account was saying that that was
her like hi taylor which one of my
family members houses did you like going
to the most harassing right you can read
the tweet right there so that's their
assertion is that that is her yeah going
to relatives houses if they showed up at
my house on my property i would smack
that mask back
and watch some charlie brown roll oh
i would just be taking the batteries out
of my ring so fun things could happen
yes
yes i'll let you in in just one second
yeah just hang on it's got a there's a
little problem here with the wiring turn
off the cameras the door would just open
like a haunted house yes let's set the
epstein stage uh real quick and i'd be
really coy about it like i put on the
table you know like some kind of i put
on the table like a vegan spread yes
can i get you anything i have more masks
to a radiator yeah some water new airpod
pros yes they're right down there in the
basement yes go ahead yes yes go down to
the wine cellar there's new airpod pros
down there go keep going so look this is
also something we had this with uh we
had this with
vox we had this with nbc universal it
was never about some uh uh um lgbtq aip
uh latin american
fair enough yeah it was about one of the
biggest media conglomerates in the world
trying to remove competition and what do
they do is they always start with
someone is the victim if lorenz is not a
victim well then people aren't as
sympathetic because it's a basic white
woman so uh at least appears to be i
don't know
i'm going going by the eyeball test now
uh same thing happened with
fox nbc universal look at this person
how could you bully this person right
look at lorenz how could libs of
tick-tock no this is someone who has the
backing of washington post owned by jeff
bezos by the way one of the richest men
in the world who is pro censorship on
the record
sorry i don't have a cough button bless
you
i just going after
an independent uh an independent
platform it's a real sneeze unlike her i
know
if you were her you'd be like
[Applause]
oh
it's terrifying she do like the uh
someone else's finger would come in yes
and it would relieve it sorry everyone i
apologize
so this uh lorenz uh taylor lorenz has a
long history by the way of playing
victim this is the playbook uh let's
bring this up for example she deleted
this post but bemoaned uh for
international women's day please
consider supporting women and during
online harassment it's not an
exaggeration to say that the harassment
and smear campaign i've had to endure
over the years has destroyed my life
i can't believe that i've been people
have said many things look no one should
send death threats to anybody agreed
just like no one should show up at
someone's doorstep no one should be
harassing their family members it's
destroyed my life really hasn't
destroyed your life well then why are
you destroying someone else's or
attempting to
we're gonna get we're gonna get the
troops
as rallied as we possibly can
don't play victim here sweetheart you
entered the arena
oh and we know that liberals would never
send a death threat to any of us no
never times not like when we were in
detroit we had to have
a security that would put suge knight's
crew to shame well not to mention the
threat sent
to the venue yes
[Laughter]
the good thing is you know since we
don't do uh just free shows you know
with a non-profit people actually
purchase tickets well guess what that
also kind of keeps the libs at bay
because they don't want to pay for
tickets now also any slightly cold
temperature seems to change how hard
they're willing to go yes exactly
so here's the thing she says it's
destroyed my life the online harassment
taylor lorenz has made her entire career
by looking through social media posts
and
i hate the word cancel because it's just
it's it's it's not heavy enough and
trying to remove people's livelihoods
because of it wars have been fought for
less it's why i always get mad when they
say give the give the land to native
americans which tribe they were warring
over land why
so that they could they could either
forge depending if they were nomadic or
depending if they were sanitary at that
point they could basically live off of
that land they were fighting over
resources guess what that's your
livelihood just change a bow and arrow
with an iphone screen with a laptop so
she has made her career taylor lorenz
looking for people to cancel last year
when writing for the new york times what
a poor poor thing my career has been
destroyed writing for the new york times
and washington post by the way you [ __ ]
about billionaire class
you're owned by them yes you are owned
by them and this is going to really piss
you off because people know that i can't
be bought sold or reasoned with
when it comes to this there's nothing
you can do
that's going to stop this freight train
coming your way lorenz so
she uh attempted to cancel this uh tech
entrepreneur a guy named mark
anderson andreessen i don't know how
it's pronounced exactly
if i got that wrong i'm sorry it's not
at the top of my priority list today
now deleted post so she tweeted just
open she said that this guy uh mark just
openly
using the r slur on club very poorly
written grammatically in case you're
saying why am i getting confused it
doesn't really make a whole and it took
me a while i was like arsler [ __ ]
hmm ah well she's a writer oh new york
times right just openly using the arsler
on clubhouse tonight and not one other
person in the room called him on it or
saying anything you're a professional
writer a and b
shut up
how about that
maybe people didn't call them on it
because people
aren't hyperly sensitive professional
victims like yourself
[ __ ]
he was just asking you to move yes
he shouldn't have said the
r words say what yes that's true that
was childhood and she kept saying what
yeah i know well you know what it works
that's the problem that's why he keeps
doing it
so
in reality the guy never even used the
slur
right so all lorenz did was what this is
after she tried to destroy the man's
career over this sort of half-assed
retraction many heard mark's voice
saying the r word because it was male
at 405 talking about a time code in the
audio uh in it you can hear ben say alex
maybe you could take us through the
[ __ ] revolution i hope everyone who
uses word can think more carefully about
why blah blah blah blah blah blah
shut up shut up it's like i shot the
wrong guy but this guy robbed a bank i
hope we can all think i'm kind of
[ __ ] you're the one
you're the one who committed the misdeed
and i love it by the way says r word
because it was male so all males sound
alike now to be fair all screeching fake
whiners sound alike to me so you kind of
you blend
right if you go after somebody and try
to ruin their career ruin their
livelihood make sure that they cannot
provide for their family the least that
you can do is to go out and own the
mistake that you made you just had a
session where you said that your life
has been so tough and nobody should have
to go through this
what if what you had just endured was
actually somebody else's fault and the
person who put you through this hell
just said well maybe she can think twice
about this next time uh but you know
before we do those kinds of things yeah
would that help would that do anything
for you well her alleged fake crying
don't get me wrong i don't legit well
alleged fake crying we don't know uh in
her case it's an immutable
characteristic because she won't shut up
that's true she does chat a lot it's
probably just aware that her chickens
are going to come home to roost at some
point and son she's a uh potentially i i
don't have any proof of this is looking
at her sociopath you're the [ __ ] of the
walk baby yeah oh no oh she's
not good
now her face she doesn't have any
emotion uh yeah she's um i just think
she's a sociopath and she's trying to
cover her tracks before and after yeah
so she is absolutely right it's pathetic
no it's this is sociopathic behavior
someone who only makes their living
trying to destroy others now so yeah
comedians listen it's very different to
make fun of things as part of a show
that provides solutions and references
and sketches this is all she does and
she's funded by the ultra wealthy
billionaire class to do it by the way
the class of a dying media again the
pattern is non-profit highlight reel hit
piece legitimized by mainstream media
that's why they want to have
professional fact checkers that's why
you have gen saki and you have this
administration saying we would love to
see more people put more fact checks on
these uh pieces of content that's
misinformation that's leaning online so
non-profit hit piece legitimized by
mainstream media social media gives it
the right of way it doesn't require a
conspiracy to see that they're all
working together and by the way when
it's something that they don't like they
do the opposite they go from trusted
media outlets one day to the next
they're like no we're not gonna let you
have this hunter biden story no we're
gonna throttle your account so that you
can't reach as many followers up you're
suspended for violating our terms of
service right our user service agreement
for whatever rule that we won't actually
tell you violated and where you made the
violation and if you tried to take that
post down that violated it's still not
going to get you back on the account
we'll wait about seven to ten days when
this is all blown over and nobody wants
to hear what you have to say anymore
then we'll put you back on exactly right
and unfortunately uh unfortunately
was there a feather in here pollen
that's what happened i must have sneezed
it open
um no yeah you're absolutely right and
unfortunately you have a lot of people
on the right who then abandon them and
it's like well that story's no longer
hot let's move on to the next one of
course we won't and you better not
we need to start helping our own and
supporting our own and hiring our own
that's why we have the golden
sweepstakes where we hire people that's
why we develop strategic partnerships
hey that's why the nothing would make me
happier than to watch all of this
meaning social media meaning their
stranglehold information burned to the
ground i would love it if all of you
right now switch from youtube to rumble
or switch from
youtube to rumble or mug club yeah i
would love it if you did the problem is
a lot of you don't
and a lot of us are complacent where we
can't be bothered to hit open tab and
then we [ __ ] about why no one's why no
one is leaning in why no one is filling
that gap guess what people are yeah
people are this is also something that
happens a lot with us like why is there
no why is there no uh
right leaning alternative to and they
named the late night shows well you're
watching it yeah you're watching it what
do you mean something on nbc abc they're
never going to let you in stop trying to
co-op in co-op institutions we are
needing to create our own and that's
what we're trying to do here so that we
can have an umbrella of protection for
people like lives of tick-tock for
people like kyle rittenhouse who never
would have been able to say the kinds of
things that he said
even on conservative leaning traditional
media okay so let's continue with this
uh taylor lorenz
the accusation that she's making
she i don't want to misgender her the
chi what are your preferred pronouns
lorenz that's a good question
um
wine win
i have no idea
cry crying she accuses z accuses uh libs
of tick tock of uh
leaning hard quote leaning hard into
groomer discourse so here you go in this
uh this little tweet this clip uh uh
libs of tick tock literally quoted the
teacher babies are born the doctor looks
at them and they make a guess about
whether the baby is a boy how do they
make that guess based on what they look
like and most of the time that guess is
100 correct there are no issues
whatsoever um
but sometimes the doctor is wrong the
doctor makes an incorrect guess
it's the worst doctor says [ __ ] yeah
no no this is wait what happened are you
a biologist that's a public school
teacher the lowest of the low i'm sorry
real heroes that's true yes essential
workers yes essential you imagine that
like 20 years ago i don't know that's
just i mean what do you guys think it's
got a it's got one of them thingies with
balls what do i say
[Music]
is that a third leg oh my gosh i don't
know how do we label the celebratory
cigars that we're smoking in the er oh
no
doctor cockburn get in here
congratulations you've had a oh i'm
gonna go i don't know exactly this has
been a two martini delivery
johnny bench over there by the way it's
not just penis
it's weight
it's i mean these these are there
there's a lot that's taken into account
by the way i've had twins okay i've
experienced this and unlike the john
money twin study which is
it is the centerpiece it is a foundation
for modern gender theory the the john
money twins study
where he raised one as a boy one is a
girl
they both die one killed himself i think
the other was a drug overdose so they
both killed himself he sexually abused
them put them in sexually dominant
positions that's the basis for all of
this that you're seeing out there let's
be really clear about it yes i would
consider that grooming to try and tell
children that doctors are wrong where
are the are you a biologist people and
the other headlines shared by the
account by the way speak for themselves
with libs of tick tock they do a
wonderful job of just bringing from one
echo chamber the crazy lgbtq aaip their
exact words
and just allowing you to see them so
that you don't have to wander off into
that dark soul sucking chamber of the
internet
but if you are a biologist and you
answer the question they tell you you're
wrong right well that's what differences
yes the uh preschool teacher tells you
that you're wrong right
and by the way a preschool teacher can
tell a biologist that they're wrong if
they're
just refusing to acknowledge science if
a priest was like ah penis yeah prequel
teacher can be right in this case it's
just the roles that reversed
so lorenz also by the way tried to
accuse uh libs of tick tock of being
anti-trans
this is again this is the playbook
victim victim victim victim victim
victim victim for telling
uh the followers of this uh profile
lives of tick tock to contact schools
that were allowing boys in the girls
bathroom i don't know that sounds fairly
reasonable to me more reasonable than uh
a dump with a tube of lipstick and a
fake mustache
it's also lazy we had to try to sneak
into the girls locker rooms yeah you
have to cut a hole yeah and you peek
through it yes like porkies yes
or like you know
everywhere yeah everywhere
like davies mine was cinderblock it
required a dremel just a restaurant
i don't even serve anything i'm like i
just got bathrooms yeah is that weird
farther than that it's really a it's
really a truck stop shaped like a
restaurant
do you have gas no no you have a 90s
camcorder for the camera we can see it
dave you just hung it from the ceiling
and it's shoulder mounted
brother i just buy all of chuck berry's
restaurant
now here's here's uh these are the
allies who are brought in um by the way
whenever someone uses the term ally
and they're not talking about world war
ii piece of [ __ ]
so lorenz
herself isn't uh isn't uh slimy enough
so she decided to quote ra drenin the
lgbtq program director four for the
non-profit media matters
who says in the piece
it feels like libs of tick tock
single-handed is single-handedly taking
us back a decade in terms of the public
discourse around lgbtq rights hey you
know what you know what again since they
post content in context unedited
i would say
that the lgbtq community is doing that
if this seems long
wait to the end
animals
congressman
what
are you serious this is a school
assembly
[Applause]
[Music]
that's like a science teacher want to
take a guess at the gender
[Music]
[Applause]
now what if that were just a straight
white woman oh man
[Music]
uh her dad might have been there try the
fish thing for a day gender literally
just means multiple genders or many
genders we live in a world where
mainstream society has decided and
agreed that there are two genders and we
call them male and female or masculine
and feminine and they correspond with
genitalia
um but there are those of us who
regardless of what's going on with our
bodies identify with characteristics
from either end of that spectrum or
places in between that spectrum or even
entirely outside of that spectrum okay a
couple things i love how this person
says first off uh
just just see remember the left the
place so that the the the alcove for
people like the dan rather's whose
producers maybe not him forged documents
uh are upset that uh of course libs of
tiktok is taking the literary license of
putting on a watermark that's how
transformative they are of the content
just putting on their watermark oh my
god is that where is that the hate
speech that it just says libs of tick
tock because that's all they're doing
second i love how that person says
regardless of what's going on with your
body oh we can just do that we can just
take something that's real and say
regardless of it and then make something
up like regardless of this bullet
penetrating your rib cage i don't
believe that i don't believe that i shot
him your honor and i should be free to
go well she said regardless he said
regardless [ __ ]
however she's like anywhere in the
spectrum and then in just in case maybe
outside of that spectrum you come up
with something completely all over we're
not supposed to talk about [ __ ] i
just want to say that normally i think
it's sad when dogs get euthanized
did they say congressman
sorry i was holding that in minutes
i think we should send them to
congressman
yeah that was a sound bite
is that a grown-up thing to do
congressman
yeah don't bother me
i'm in character
daniel the congressman is daniel day
lewis and his sex dog slave role his
their sex dog slaves in the movie
shivers when an std alien takes it for a
hotel and that's a congressman
i can't get over this
hey
you watch your hate speech no no i i
would never i know you saying no i'm
saying it's sad no but you just you just
described it accurately you have to say
regardless and then you're safe oh
regardless yeah good thank you now you
got it regardless yeah like i think it's
i think it would be sad if the dogs were
euthanized that's what i said well yeah
never right yeah
you wouldn't i wouldn't if my friend did
that i wouldn't be like immediately take
him to the pound and be like he's 30
he's probably in a lot of pain
regardless regardless regardless oh you
got it just follow the bouncing
certifiable patient
even the dogs like i hate you yeah
i mean
could they please like just do that with
a pit bull oh yeah oh i hope so off
leash
oh my gosh oh just take joe lewis just
take joe lewis one of those places like
i don't look
regardless
of the 500 psi byte pressure uh you know
regardless regardless
i don't i don't think that uh you're in
any sort of uh figurative regardless
drive a couple of new fighting dogs into
mexico yeah what is michael vick showing
up to this
these ones are champs geez
yeah can someone get michael vick and a
bathtub
[Music]
anywho but limbs of tick-tock
how could you do this they're showing
you exactly what and we've had this
happen too again what did we do when we
had the vox apocalypse sorry about that
youtube created what is known as the
crowder rule oops uh oops and again this
is because we crossed our t's dotted our
eyes very expensive and legal fees
just so you know
um
we we would provide long clips rebut
them and say by the way go watch the
full video go watch it for its full
context we probably gave the videos we
were butting more plays than they
initially had because we want you to see
the left for what it is we want you to
see the truth whether you agree with me
with dave it's gerald
and it was tool main with token out with
whoever it is take your pick or not
we absolutely do create a program it's
live we provide the references publicly
we make ourselves there's there's no
possible way to be more transparent
what does this person do taylor lorenz
what does vox do they hide behind a
media non-profit some kind of one-way
mainstream outlet and let social media
do the bidding you do can you comment
below if you're we i know that there are
a lot of classical liberals who watch do
you see the difference in the approach
of transparency can you at least give us
that credit that we we try we try
regardless
right yeah because you actually are
legitimate we try to do it yeah and i
get that we can tell some you know jokes
every now and then but i think that
that's part of it like the problem is
they can get [ __ ] we are joking
though they're dead serious yes that's
the problem
there is a difference jokes should not
be taken as anything serious they're
jokes that's it well this is the problem
is you have an entire generation of
people who are raised with no irony no
understanding no understanding is why i
can no longer be friends i can no longer
have intimate relationships with
liberals i mean this this is why what
you are seeing today when people talk
about the destruction of america when
people talk about oh the mistrust sonar
institutions i can no longer
have close friendships with
leftist let me explain to you i used to
be able to
but it's just that now it's too
exhausting to explain it for example if
you're just sitting and you say you know
they mentioned the florida don't say gay
bill now you would one once upon a time
they would be informed enough where you
could say well of course it doesn't
say that in the bill and they would say
well i know but we're just sort of using
that you know the nomenclatures that
we're describing the sentiment of the
bill but today if you have a liberal
friend who says they don't say gay bill
you say that's not in the bill i said
yes it is you can't have a conversation
then you have to start from the
beginning
it's like running out of lives and mario
and you have to start from scratch i
don't want to do this
you're even just at a restaurant like
excuse me waitress and you look over and
your friends just shaking
how dare you and you're like what um
what did what i say person serving a
server
how do you know her gender i i don't
know she's it deserves sarah yeah
server sounds a lot more like slave
mistake sticking with waitress
yep oh i'm gonna sit at a different
table yeah
different friends no food by the way
because it's your truck stop slash chuck
berry restaurant so yes it's also
important to remember bathroom sarah
who employs it's important to remember
here who employs taylor lorenz
washington post
jeff bezos one of the good billionaires
right yes one of the good ones one of
the good ones unlike that elon musk yeah
that phone you can't trust him with his
free speech yes elon musk who wants more
voices again let me ask you comment
below please it helps the youtube
algorithm grinds their gears does anyone
out there actually believe
that elon musk wants less freedom than
jeff bezos
does anyone actually believe that if you
give twitter over to jeff bezos versus
elon musk you mean how he pays people a
livable wage right
does anyone actually believe if you
could give it over to one of these two
that it would be the same that it would
be comfortable again just
elon musk i guarantee you is not an
actual he's not a conservative he's not
from here
but he's a guy who sees at least now the
american dream for what it is and by the
way the american dream wasn't always
just a dog and like white picket fence
it was the right to have that because
that was desirable
but also to not
so it's important to compare these two
are you seeing the trend no transparency
removal of voices versus opening it up
and that's not without consequences i'm
not saying that because when you open it
up you're going to get some ugly voices
too but guess what
you have to if you want to have the good
voices so on april 17th the editorial
board at washington post published
a piece titled let's hope elon musk
doesn't win his bid for twitter hey
remember how you guys talked about
citizens united which you don't really
know what that was about that was
actually about a documentary about
hillary clinton in the right to free
political speech but you talk about the
billionaire class and donations and
lobbyists and how much you hate it this
is a billionaire trying to snuff out
competition where are you oh you're
siding with the guy trying to silence
a twitter profile
a twitter profile
that just shows content in its entirety
and speaking of hope with the washington
post uh let's hope elon musk doesn't win
his bid for twitter brian stelter
tweeted this to philip bump who works
for the washington post tucker carlson
is always telling the same thing philip
bump says he's selling doubt and then
jack dorsey said and you are all selling
hope
well it's a fair point jack but you're a
little late to the game yeah slightly
late to the party after you know ruining
everything a day late and a pube beard
too short yes indeed wilson
well fine
well
so
only if you know wilson had free will
he'd be like
no
oh thank you
i identify as queer yes a nice nose i'm
gone
uh oh he would have died immediately
because he wouldn't be willing to learn
spear fishing so the washington post
uh and the journalists like taylor
lorenz they're terrified of course of
lords of tik-tok for the same reason
they're terrified of elon musk
what did i say
i like that that's pretty good i like
yeah
if they remove
hey somebody on our staff go get that
name
we'll give it to him herb lens of tick
tock
your new gender
i'm herbling the little fontel royce of
tiktok yes the frontal
so um this is the problem is their their
great sin is exposing the united states
you to more information and that will
threaten the stranglehold and you know
what yeah we do when people talk about
uh
the left does this and they say well the
first amendment
or the second amendment only applies to
muskets
i understand that you mean to imply that
technology sometimes changes context i
get that uh maybe we need to change the
word monopoly because monopoly
monopolies usually think of one company
right usually think of one company maybe
like ge back in the day something like
that uh but we really do have
effectively effectively a monopoly
when media and all social media
and places like amazon places like the
podcast or
the uh the apple store apple store apple
store the app store app they have so
many used to be itunes i can't keep up
anymore why change it from itunes to
apple music i don't get it but the point
is when they all get together and they
can remove one person immediately when
it happened with alex jones it happens
in the span of one day everywhere you
think that happened by accident it
happens all the time guess what that's
effectively a monopoly that's a monopoly
and by the way they have a seal of
approval the stamp of the united states
government
worse than that they have the united
states government saying we need more we
need more you have jin saki saying we
would like to see more of this done we
have hearings in congress and we're like
oh thank god they're finally going to go
after facebook no no you didn't do
enough
to silence voices really
because that's what this country was
built on silencing voices we disagree
with that's never gone out of control in
the history of man has it yeah hey just
all i'm asking you to do
leftist keep your protests up
against the jeff phases of the world
because of you know whatever it was the
union yeah aoc just just don't stop just
keep it going for the [ __ ] he's pulling
now
oh you're gonna take a break well yes
all right
so in uh libs of tik tok their own words
can we say her name because it was yeah
she was outed unfortunately in this
article yeah i think so yeah i think so
i mean shot there right yeah she she was
added and they actually also gave some
like work deal details yeah about what
she'd done like real estate so they took
they took that out um washington posted
they did but
by the way okay let me just be clear
about something too they know that of
course they they know that they didn't
go oh oh we're washing so either
you're you're morons and you deserve to
die figuratively regardless whatever i
need to say as far as a media entity or
you're dishonest you're either dumb or
dishonest you didn't know that if you
left it up and it was trending number
one two and three on twitter and
facebook and and i don't know where it
is on google trends right now right now
it's it's 11 18 eastern 10 18 central
for those who can't be bothered to go
through the anguish and subtracting one
you guys didn't know that that would be
publicly available and still destroy her
life and that time machine is something
that exists of course you do yeah or a
phone that you can take a screenshot
with right if you take it down right i
know exactly what you're doing in the
article i was reading through it this
morning again in the article there was a
throwaway line didn't need it didn't
matter to the story at all i did this
and found name and cell phone right in
the article i'm like why would you put
that in there other than to make this
person's life hell
why it didn't matter to the story at all
of course no other reason there's no
other and by the way when we've done
people have said well you do the crowd
we do crowd or confronts we've done that
series uh when people have threatened to
kill me
or falsely accuse me of threatening to
kill their children or fire bomb our van
yeah or slash our tires we've never
confronted some random person and even
when we do it we don't give you their
public information as far as their
address and their phone number by the
way those are fewer and far further
between because people don't want to
make the death threats anymore libs of
tick tock
we've got your back
we know how to put these people on their
heels and i know you have some people
say oh controlled opposition that's why
they're a lot on youtube they seem like
controlled opposition to you they seem
like i give a [ __ ] if tomorrow youtube
wants to remove us and we we
we live off of what we kill on mug club
and rumble
this sound like a guy who gives a rat's
so
uh this is what shia said at libs of tik
tok no uh i'm not some politician or
blue blue check journalist by the way
the grammar is so much better than the
professional writer odd
i feel like there are so many small
stories that are so important that
aren't getting out
and that's what i'm here for
so look this is something i will say you
know we haven't been able to get a hold
of of tick tock this morning but uh
we've talked to them in the past behind
the scenes we think that this is a
profile uh this is a platform that they
have that is incredibly valuable
and it's important work
and i i can't say that this uh that shia
is a friend i've only spoken in limited
capacity seems like a really decent
person and what i can tell you is
somebody who is genuine and so lives of
tick tock look
uh
reach out
reach out because i know right now
you're going to have the nonprofits
rolling and the lawyers swirling and a
lot of you people here watching right
now you don't see what goes on behind
the scenes tim the tool man knows he's
worked in quite a few of the big media
outlets as well in the past uh you're
only as valuable as the trend today you
are as valuable to us tomorrow and the
day after as you were yesterday because
the work that you do and because of what
you believe in and we need to start
supporting our own so hopefully we'll be
announcing some kind of
what can we say gerald maybe maybe some
we we've been working on something
behind the scenes with lives of tick
tock and hopefully we can give you an
update
soon about that it's been going on for a
while right and this changes none of
that and and a big reason for it is you
you heard me tell you i said
they're circling yeah so they're
circling i said watch they're gonna once
you're too effective they start going
after you absolutely and what they do is
they take their shots and if this here's
the thing if this doesn't work
they'll try it again in a few months
that's what they did with us right the
vox apocalypse doesn't work
back up a little bit then they come back
one more time they keep doing it because
they realize it's not working they're
losing public favor
and then they come back this is what's
going to happen if lives of tick-tock is
not de-platformed and i pray and i
genuinely all said a prayer before this
show i pray that they are not
these people are going to come back and
guess what the second time all these
mainstream outlets including
conservatives they'll say that already
happened it's not a trend they won't be
there to support these people yeah
andrew breitbart didn't do that well
guess what is coming up too that uh this
the timing is oh just such a coincidence
yeah yeah something about something
about elections were people about a
kotex red wave yeah yeah people are a
little pissed off about their kids being
indoctrinated in schools and that's one
of her passions is exposing what's going
on in schools right now and that's
motivating a lot of people to go out and
vote differently than they have in the
past and interesting and i'll tell you
this we would really love nothing more
than you know here uh to
be able to broadcast some of the uh
small stories that aren't getting out
there
uh and we have a limited budget we have
a limited production staff i would love
to have you know boots on the ground
everywhere i don't cnn does washington
post does new york times does what's
your excuse you do nothing with it
nothing think about it for a second
washington post all of that money jeff
bezos funding it
and this is what's trending from the
washington post all boarding is someone
writing a piece
doxxing family members effectively
really
and you wonder why there's no trust in
journalism
anyways comment below
smash the like button if you uh if
you're still here we're gonna have to do
the math mandate i think tomorrow yeah
can we can we end with a yeah yeah we
will we have something we have something
that's fine by the way dave and i will
be in colorado springs again june 18th
there are some tickets left i think
tulsa sold out
yes also i believe just sold out yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i think there's
some there might be like 50 tickets that
are released because sometimes family
members reservations and they don't they
don't show up i mean but yeah this
weekend if anybody or just saturday
actually just the funny bunch yeah so go
to livestream.com
and i tell you what it's a lot of fun to
see the reason it's valuable is just to
see how many people like you there are
out there right and that's not really
the case with the nonprofit speeches
that take place on college campuses it's
it's and i appreciate what they do i
really do
but half of those people are just kids
who are wandering and half of them are
liberals where they're protests when you
show up at a venue and you see a theater
of two three thousand people and
everyone is there
right it's a brother that's a sister and
they're just laughing having a good time
guess what there are a lot of people
like you out there this today is another
example of the media wants you to feel
alone
they want everyone to watch this and go
oh oh well yeah
yeah i can't i can't believe it yeah you
can
yeah you can and you know it's right and
you should support it
if you put distance between yourself and
the lives of tick-tock of the world or
the cal written asses of the world
or the next salmons of the world whoever
it is
[ __ ] i just gendered you in a
derogatory way now
everywhere that they i know they're on
twitter i know that they ironically not
tick-tock not well yeah yeah
i know they have instagram but is
twitter their biggest platform i think
twitter is their biggest fighter
instagram
like this under our wing and produce it
you know i've talked about this i don't
want to announce my when i retire but i
have a kind of a plan of when i would
like to step back someone else take
these rings and be able to produce other
shows and other content yeah
unfortunately unfortunately but the
truth is behind the scenes most
conservatives and media are very very
lazy and i can tell you this lived with
tick-tock they're not that they're
they're i can count on one hand
one hand the amount of people in
conservative media whose work ethic i
actually respect
they're one of them
and that's why they haven't been able to
produce a lot of shows here we've
brought some people in they're like oh
this is just a lot well yeah yeah it is
that's what it takes and that's why we
fight like hell every day but right now
let's uh end this on on a i mean i can
say funny slash sad it's very our word
note
uh sunday crowds of course were
gathering easter right they were
celebrating it at the white house and uh
uh good thing for former vice president
joe biden
dr jill biden and the easter bunny were
there to make sure that um
well he didn't soil himself
wait if you have a problem figuring out
whether you're for me or trump and you
ain't black welcome to the south lawn
thank you and happy happy easter
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
come on
[Music]
wait if you have a problem figuring out
whether you're for me or trump then you
ain't black oh before i go i almost
forgot uh i forgot uh you know we're
gonna do the mask mandate uh story and
yeah even though regardless of that look
this is one thing using adjunct is a
clear nasal spray that i use before
every flight and um
uh slash
[Music]
flash
slash slash what uh that wasn't that was
incredible i think it was really good
amazing
did you relapse and uh start using coke
again
maybe yeah you can hear you're very
nasally yeah
yeah it's not good for your pacemaker
yeah
that's you did didn't you terrible well
look okay try this i was gonna use it
before my flight here tonight but uh
it's a clear nasal spray that'll uh
clear up your uh that'll clear it up
right there yeah yeah yeah give it a
whirl it's got xylitol in there and it
creates a like a biofilm that prevents
anything from sticking to it i've never
been able to breathe this well before
[Music]
yeah i should sorry your nose is
something
it's very clear it's going to be a while
before you're
you're able to rock again
[Music]
oh man it's so clear you can't feel any
of the coke no that's the problem
it's like music magic ah that's enough
the magic potion but don't use it kids
unless you want to rock like slash
uh
look
let's try to be a rock go wash your nose
this is one thing we've talked about
like if you guys want to use mass don't
use math there's no reason to not you
can go see the fda studies it's got
xylitol in there which actually it
deactivates a lot of viruses and it
creates like a moisture a slick kind of
coating in your nasal i use it before
every single flight because you're
breathing and you're breathing
everyone's you know
just their their their their their cold
cuts and budweiser farts yeah well
listen it's not the sexy thing to do but
it is definitely something that will
help you stay healthy this is a great
thing to do is constantly to wash your
nose yeah you brush your teeth you wash
your face
wash your nose is sexy yeah i mean
people don't i mean people may not like
50 shorts helpful submit your sexiest
nose wash
that's right do it oh boy come on ladies
no guys just ladies seriously don't well
if you're a guy that's a construct
stephen
okay
and it's available by the way at most
over the counter like pharmacies amazon
i've been using it for years and you
know what they have the balls to sponsor
them so we have a few sponsors that are
fantastic it's just products that i've
used before they became a sponsor thank
you clear and i recommend you try it
we're gonna go play guess that gender
youtube
piss off
so
[Music]
you